season 11. people love
jen this year i know who knew
how are you receiving all the love i
love it it's great i feel like um this
season
people are really going to get to see a
lot more of my personality
whereas like you know before people just
didn't get it
i'm loving seeing every side of you
let's unpack everything
the season started with a bang are we
finally putting the jackie teresa saga
behind us starting this week
i mean unfortunately it continues at the
pool party
theresa gave her version of an olive
branch
we all saw what jackie did with that
olive branch so now
teresa's like oh okay you know what now
thank you
trademark theresa that's how she is she
says sorry not sorry
type of thing which i totally get by the
way
in talking to jackie it seems like she
thinks that you will do anything to
remain friends with theresa
that you will kiss teresa's butt no
matter what what is your response to
to that claim it's interesting when
margaret defends theresa
it's oh margaret i think you're smarter
than that oh you're giving her a pass
but when i defend someone who is
actually my friend
that's kissing her ass no sweetheart
that's called friendship so get the memo
if you haven't already gotten it i told
theresa i thought what she did was wrong
however i'm not gonna sit here and start
a fight with my real friend over someone
who's
you know somewhat of a friend i mean
people were always saying like
oh um you know who talks about the host
of a party when you're at that party
right
do you know how many weddings i've been
to where
the bride was marrying a dog and we were
all sitting there at the table like i
can't believe she's actually marrying
him
so i'm just like confused about why
everybody's so shocked
i think it's actually nicer that she
didn't tell jackie to her face at her
party
that would have been rude teresa took
the nice way out and did it like
everybody else
behind their backs i mean i think in an
ideal situation she would have pulled
jackie aside one-on-one at
not a party and told her and not talk of
course and again like uh
i told her that to pivot to the drama
that fled over from last season you and
melissa
we kind of saw you making aims with her
getting to a better place where are
things now
i think melissa and i are in a good
place i mean you know
at the end of the day she doesn't bother
me uh i don't know if she's bothered by
me
but in in my defense like i just kill
him with kindness like let's kiki
it up and move on so i'm hoping that she
feels the same
were you surprised that she did not
shoot the messenger when you brought
michelle the realtor's
story to her oh absolutely absolutely
when we were at jackie's party michelle
told me that
her husband and your husband were
supposed to split the growing with gorga
thing
and your husband never paid him she said
the amount was like tens of thousands of
dollars
tens of thousands what the are you
talking about
i mean i was on pins and needles because
it's like we just went through this
whole fiasco with somebody saying a
rumor
and it didn't go so well so i was just
like let me try to take a different
approach and hopefully her reaction
will be different which it was so i was
grateful for that
now this michelle woman i mean it
the way it's coming across on the show
is that she stepped in and wanted to
mess
stuff up do you feel like she maybe used
you a little here no
not at all she is not a starter and let
me tell you
even though michelle and i had not met
up until that point
we had communicated via text and through
instagram so i feel like we already had
some kind of connection
and maybe she felt that she could trust
me i think michelle is a straight-up
person
okay i think she came to say her truth
and
the way that it was spun maybe it
backfired but
she still stands by her word and you
know what it's not my fight anyway
so right like the learning from evan's
party was if you hear something or have
an issue with somebody just maybe tell
them and not somebody else
100 100 we know that
drama with michelle and her husband
trickles into the pool party we're going
to see some
some movement on that in the next
episode but this pool party
how much of the pool party do you
actually remember jennifer
jennifer's acting like she's going to be
mom
don't fall down oh
i remember everything until getting into
the pool
for tequila pong and the only thing
after that i remember
is what i thought of as at the time was
an
out-of-body experience but i know now
that they were just
carrying me and i was just witnessing
the sky
move i know now that i was being carried
to the car but at the time i just
thought i was having an
out-of-body experience you thought you
were floating okay
uh was part of the out-of-body
experience you singing countess luanne
say what money can't buy you clowns
and i didn't even remember that i had
done that somebody had recorded that and
sent that to me after and i was like oh
my god i hope this makes it into the
show
[Laughter]
you know this has been teased since the
trailer came out this pool party moment
this drunken moment it's implied in the
trailer that maybe you've turned to
alcohol
to numb the pain you're feeling why is
she drinking so much every time i see
her she is drinking something inhaling
something
she numbs herself to a lot of her issues
do you think that's true at all
i think it's 100 not true i am only a
social drinker
and because i don't drink that often i
don't know my tolerance
and then when theresa wanted everybody
to play to kill a pong
i didn't want to be like all negative
nancy i wanted to be like a team player
so i was like
i'll play and then of course it got the
best of me and what you see is what i
see for the first time on the show
i think it's just going to be bomb oh my
god
what is your reaction to seeing yourself
in that state
um i mean you're like pouring water on
yourself i thought it was hysterical i
thought it was hysterical i threw up
that night like four times and margaret
told me how she was
driving past me and she's like oh my god
i felt so bad you were throwing up on
the side of the car and my first
instinct was did you get it on camera
[Laughter]
and she was like no i thought about it
but i didn't want to do it to you and i
was like nah [ __ ]
that is tv gold honey you get it on
camera and let's show everybody and then
next time you will see i do not get that
drunk
at all for the rest of the season teaser
and if you really want to ask me if i
have any regrets about
the pool party it's only that i didn't
get a spray tan
before i would have appreciated
some tan legs and butt crack looks but
you know you really don't care that this
is airing on tv
that because this is just so do you
think the conversation that's in that
trailer where they say she's numbing
herself to deal with the pain that's
like a projection
that these women were putting on to you
maybe i don't know where they're coming
from i mean numbing what
pain yes i'm stressed out i was dealing
with the drama
of my parents i'm still dealing with the
drama of my parents
but if i want to let loose and have a
good time last i checked i was 21 and
over
thanks you bring up the situation with
your parents
my mom and my dad have been bickering a
lot lately
[Music]
so i made an executive decision to have
my dad live with me
where do things stand today what can you
tell me about the journey we're gonna
watch in the second half of the season
my mom has always been with my
with me she's always been my ride or die
since day one
it's always been me and my mom it's just
this small
chapter now that we are evolving to that
my dad happens to be more involved
and that's only because the jewelry
store went out of business
our family jewelry store went out of
business
causing my father not to have a job to
go to every day
it's very sad for him he's dealing with
his own trauma
and and feelings of loss it's just like
an
influx of a change that they were forced
to deal with and you know what
it pissed them off my mother and my
father were both like
angry depressed and i was trying to find
a way
to referee them both but in my mother's
eyes the more that i defended my father
in her eyes the more i was going against
her betty you turned
my kids against me the things he said to
me
it's hurt and i tried to explain to her
that although
he's your husband and you have one
feeling towards him
i wanted my mother to understand that
he's also my father
and she has to understand the love and
respect i have for my father
is your dad still living with you are
they still living separately my dad is
still living with me
um my mother and i we got into
a fight a couple months ago and we
haven't spoken since
my mom just can't accept the fact that
i'm trying to make everybody happy here
and she
doesn't care if i make her happy she
just wants to make sure i don't make my
father happy and for me i don't want to
choose size
my father never makes me choose a side
so i'm just caught in the middle and
right now my mother and i are not
speaking
wow that's very sad to hear why is
divorce not an option for them they
don't believe in divorce
they they believe that this is what god
planned for me
and i must accept it so it's it's
unfortunate because i would love for
both of them to be happy
but my mother told me if i divorced your
dad when i wanted to
none of you would have ever gotten
married to somebody from our community
because it's just a matter of also like
in her
eyes the perception of people middle
eastern people
care so much about what their culture
thinks of them
like they almost revolve their lives
around it and it's like you know what
ultimately these people
don't give a bit about you anyway so
what do you care it sounds like
the journey is kind of just beginning
then there's a lot of conversations left
to have whenever she's willing to have
them
my mother has started therapy and we are
starting
family therapy together i think that's
going to be a great way for us to
integrate back into each other's lives
that's probably something i won't
showcase on the show
because it's my mother's journey and i
just want to find a way
to be able to have a relationship with
my mother without my
relationship with my father affecting it
yeah
probably bringing in a third party will
help that's what i mean somebody like
unbiased that can be a mediator so that
both of us can say
our side of the story we all have a role
to play
but it starts off with self-reflection
and i'm hoping that the therapy can help
us get there
yeah all right well back to the what we
are going to see on the show we know
this shore trip is coming up
yes from my understanding there's like
a joe margaret jackie situation and then
the
joe melissa teresa situation
which moment is gonna shock the audience
more
joe gorga sometimes i think he deserves
to be more of a housewife than melissa
somebody cut him a check right he's like
i was like what's going on here when did
he get mad
so that was definitely something
embedded in my head and melissa throwing
the cheese when it's like didn't we vow
not to throat
anymore like hello wasn't it you that
said
let's promise to not throw anything
anymore and then all of a sudden you see
some swiss in your hair
so um it was definitely quite an epic
night
and my wife is a 100 percent right
i think it speaks volumes that this cast
has been this cast for three seasons now
yeah no no changes and what do you say
to people who are speculating that a big
shake-up will come
after this season i don't think any of
us are leaving
i personally love this cast i don't i
don't care for anyone to leave but if
you want to add and shake things up
bring on a [ __ ]
[Music]
you